aux combats liés dans la cabane là-bas
dans la cabane vous mettrez en maillot
un we may you buy aux mammites oissu pat
ewing est battu mais une cote de maille
band one mais voilà au sein de cette
cabane je vous faire participer à un
petit jeu à qui joue très sympa vous
connaissez ou qui sera coanimé avec mon
ami matthieu delormeau absolument car
j'avais besoin d'un animateur à la
hauteur de ce concept et je suis le seul
animateur dans la bande
il y aura à gagner des points des points
pour aller rencontrer le père noël car
j'ai encore eu père noël hier il n'a pas
envie de tous vous voir
[Musique]
s'cusez moi les build est là ah ouais
vous mettre en maillot
cette année
bien admise touche tu étais toi je te
plaît deux secondes on tape mais vasisht
50 balles d'un interphone ça va du cd
pizza on nous rebat il sait quoi belge
de 26 ans le gall pdg de mozilla je suis
bourré de l'intérieur n'a pas tant qu'il
y est eu souvent brûlés l'intérieur donc
comme je suis fragile équilibre est
fragile à une ferrari ça des mamans
mieux qu'une mode us de limoux et sa
mère jean-michel kelly mamie
car au canal du ce a peut-être terme
dans cette pièce
merlen regard du bien pour la fin
sheridan
les chéris dame en géo poser des
questions c'est très simple on va jouer
tout de suite à questions pour un
champion glace qu il y a un bac d'eau
froide dehors à -3 degrés j'ai déjà fait
franchement ça passe pas j'avais
vraiment ça ne passe pas sachez que les
plus mauvais iront se baigner dans la
dans le bac d'eau glacée allez c'est
parti je vais démarrer par maxime gagné
quel homme politique du parti écologiste
était candidat aux élections
présidentielles de 2002 noël mamère très
bonnes réponses bravo maxime gagné bravo
maxime galy isabelle que fourton à noël
à bord
vrai ou faux
kelly pour noël la famille de michel
sapin le décor avec des guirlandes vrai
ou faux quoi tu connais michel sapin
l'inventeur du sapin c'est l'inventeur
du sapin m tu vois qu'il sait déjà donc
tu dis oui tu as dit oui tu as dit vrai
vous dites vrai ou faux kelly des
douilles atteint après michel sapin on
passe à jean-michel bull à la quel était
le prénom du personnage incarné par
marie-anne chazel dans le père noël est
une ordure
s'il n'a jamais posé bonnes réponses
quelle chanteuse qui ressemble de plus
en plus à une dinde chante en live want
for christmas dans le père noël est une
ordure quelle place se préparant son
rôle roulant sous les aisselles
du coup non c'était les doux beach ou de
sofia cassany castaldi et je vous
poserai des questions dans la boue dans
l'eau froide après pour les plus mauvais
on verra que ton sexe merci caroline
ithurbide tension question dans le film
les gremlins comment s'appelle la petite
créature offerte à billy pour noël vise
mots il a la balle de rire après minuit
au pq
absolument mais delphine qu'est-ce qu'on
retrouve à la fois sur un sapin et dans
le slip de jean-michel la ligue poule
très bonne réponse de continuer la
peinture bleue wallemme à qom occupée va
aller m'occuper des deux qui restent
mais aussi benjamin et caroline vous
avez été je sais j'avais très peur
d'aller là dans cette eau froide vous
avez peur de ce qu'on n'a pas une
hydrocution web l'hydrocution bien sûr
vous savez ce que ça veut dire
hydro cus l'eau l'eau la vie la mort
voilà donc vous avez de la chance que
vous avez des camarades extrêmement
sympathique puisque gilles verdez et
d'isabelle morini-bosc vol vous
remplacez les cherry qui veut être
représentée par exemple ce que j'ai posé
une question
moi le premier en matière médicale par
isabelle tu vas y aller ma chérie l'eau
est extrêmement froide roj
quand je vous dis même moi je respire
l'eau je me sens pas bien
alors imaginez si vous êtes dedans pas
faux de préciser qu'il a fallu casser la
glace pour faire un trou oui l'afrique
il a fallu casser la glace
pour faire un coup alors il a fallu donc
casser la glace pour faire un trou
isabelle vous allez donc représenté
caroline ithurbide attention et et
gilles tu représentes benjamin on y va
aller les chéris allez-y
olala hall alors oui jamais il à
brasilia mais ça y est bien mais faut
qu'elle reste est de répondre non non
non non il n'est pas resté vide et du
dénuement aller vite pas dû aller à leur
vie dans la loi bachelot est allé à
l'école de noël maman j'ai raté l'avion
comme le trio de cambrioleurs
je sais rien les casseurs flotteur vrai
ou faux
au pakistan les enfants reçoivent des
paquets cadeaux vous êtes incroyables et
non franchement je suis pas frileux mais
là j'ai jamais vu ça je gèle j'ai
l'impression que mes pieds vont devenir
des glaçons on m'avait dit que c'était à
0 mais c'est au moins à -20 ce truc-là
comprends même pas comment isabelle a
fait pour rentrer dedans c'est vrai que
froid concerne la viande
voilà ils sont les frileux la plus tard
c'est vraiment des minables
[Applaudissements]
jean michel maire jean michel maire je
vous le dis a failli passer parce que je
vais expliquer ce qui peut dire quoi
était fou de rage en disant mais quel
con mais quel con parce que il saute et
les guerres des courants en dessous qui
peuvent les entraîner sous la glace et
quand ils remontent il se cogne contre
la glace mais il est vraiment vu morts
alors qu'une autre option et qui parce
qu il fait tellement froid et qui tombe
dans les pommes
il coule et c'est fini il passe sous la
glace une fois que vous êtes sous la
glace unis séminaire moi c'est mon nom
qui réussit il à jongler ils ont dit on
vous l'a dit moi ça m'est arrivé un jour
j'ai dû à chercher une boîte à outils
lol non mais je vous dis non je vous
jure qu'il a failli mourir cette espèce
dormal